Je le connais, il ne doit pas être si compliqué que ça
son mot de passe.
Hmm c'est pas bon ça !
Une tentative de connexion à mon compte mail.
Je ne sais pas si vous avez déjà reçu ce genre d'alerte.
Mais moi, je n'aime pas beaucoup ça.
Je vais vous montrer comment créer
des mots de passe vraiment sécurisés.
Repérer les mails frauduleux
et protéger vos smartphones.
Et vous allez voir,
pas la peine d'être une ou un crack en informatique !
La cybersécurité nous concerne tous.
Par ce mot, on entend toutes les mesures de protection de nos appareils numériques,
des données qui y sont stockées
et plus généralement la sécurité de toutes nos informations personnelles en ligne.
Cette protection est cruciale
pour les entreprises
et les Etats qui ont des informations
stratégiques à sauvegarder.
Mais ce n'est pas qu'une affaire de pros.
Nos données privées intéressent aussi
les escrocs en tout genre.
Alors moi j'ai rien à cacher !
Ce n'est pas la question.
De la même façon qu'un voleur
peut dérober notre portefeuille.
Un cybercriminel peut piocher
dans notre compte en banque
ou faire des achats à notre place,
usurper notre identité ou consulter des photos personnelles.
Et le pire, c'est qu'on ne s'en rend pas toujours compte.
Nos données peuvent aussi
tout simplement être revendues
à des fins de ciblage publicitaire.
Les cybercriminels utilisent
la plus grande faiblesse des systèmes informatiques modernes.
Les humains !
Eh oui,
vous et moi sommes les maillons faibles dans cette histoire.
L'attaque la plus courante porte un drôle de nom.
Le phishing ou hameçonnage en français.
Il s'agit de messages frauduleux
qui prennent souvent l'apparence
d'une demande officielle
et qui visent à nous soutirer
des informations confidentielles
comme des identifiants de connexion
ou de l'argent.
Le nombre de ces arnaques
a doublé ces dernières années.
On compte aujourd'hui 600000 tentatives de phishing par semaine en France.
Tenez, rien que ce matin, j'ai reçu ce
mail, apparemment de l'Assurance Maladie.
Il a l'air comme ça, tout à fait officiel avec son beau logo,
mais j'ai un petit doute.
Je vais l'imprimer et je vais le montrer à une experte.
Alors j'ai reçu ce mail.
Un mail qui m'a été envoyé
apparemment par l'Assurance Maladie.
Je ne m'attendais pas à le recevoir
ça me semble un peu bizarre quand même.
Est-ce qu'il y a des éléments
qui doivent m'alerter ?
Tout de suite, la première chose, c'est le ton du mail.
Il est très stressant.
Il te pousse à agir très très vite,
sinon il va se passer des choses graves.
Donc on voit bien :
Bonjour, veuillez mettre à jour votre Carte Vitale. Déjà c'est un ordre.
Pour continuer à utiliser nos services.
Il va se passer quelque chose.
Il n'y aura plus de services de Carte
Vitale !
Absolument, ça continue.
Cette mise à jour doit se faire
annuellement par ses bénéficiaires.
Evidemment, nous aimerions vous revoir.
Cliquez simplement sur "Remettre à jour" pour mettre à jour vos informations
personnelles et continuer à profiter
de tous les avantages.
Sous entendu : si vous ne le faites pas,
vous perdez vos avantages.
D'où le stress que génère
ce type de méthodes. Tout à fait.
Le but de ce message, c'est
de vous mettre en situation de stress
pour court-circuiter votre réflexion
ou votre esprit critique.
Tout de suite.
Il faut y faire très attention
et prendre le temps de bien analyser
tous les détails du mail.
En fait, il faut faire tout l'inverse
de ce que l'on ressent.
C'est stressant.
Et bien au contraire, il faut se poser.
Et là, on va aller un peu plus loin.
Parfois, il arrive aussi qu'on reçoive
des messages nous indiquant
qu'on a gagné à une loterie,
que si on clique sur le lien dans les dix
minutes ou l'heure qui vient, on va gagner le dernier smartphone, par exemple.
Généralement, quand c'est trop beau pour être vrai, c'est que ce n'est pas vrai.
Dans tous les cas, il y a une urgence.
Il y a une notion d'urgence
pour vous pousser à agir vite.
C'est effectivement là
qu'il faut prendre un peu de recul.
Alors on prend du recul.
Et qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
Par exemple, la première chose, c'est
qu'on va regarder un petit peu
l'orthographe.
On se rend compte, quand on regarde
de plus près, qu'il y a des petits soucis.
Votre carte Vitale, sans "e",
ça attire vite l'œil.
C'est pas tout à fait normal.
Dès le premier mot, veuillez mettre à jour le "i"
n'est pas à la bonne place.
Ses bénéficiaires, il manque un "s".
Ensuite, l'autre chose à laquelle il va falloir prêter attention, c'est l'expéditeur.
Et on va certainement se rendre compte que ce n'est pas une adresse officielle.
Peut être un expéditeur qui vient d'un
autre pays : Belgique, Allemagne ou autre.
Ça n'est pas très crédible
pour une administration française.
Et puis on peut aussi aller
sur le site de l'administration
qui nous envoie le message.
En l'occurrence ici l'Assurance Maladie.
Et essayer de voir si on a un problème ou pas.
Tout à fait. Evidemment,
surtout pas en cliquant sur le lien
contenu dans le mail.
Mais si on a un doute,
dans ces cas là,
on peut se rendre sur le site
dont on pense que vient un l'e-mail, le site de l'Assurance Maladie, en l'occurrence.
Surtout par votre lien habituel.
Et là, vous verrez bien ce qui se passe.
S'il devait y avoir un problème,
on vous le signalera.
Mais surtout, surtout,
ne jamais cliquer sur le lien.
Jamais cliquer sur un lien.
Que ce soit pour gagner un smartphone, gagner à la loterie,
mettre à jour une information vitale.
Surtout, on va toujours sur les sites
par les accès que l'on connaît déjà.
Alors ça, c'est ce qu'il ne faut pas faire.
Mais est-ce qu'il y a des choses à faire ?
Au contraire, est-ce que
ce type de message doit être signalé ?
Vous pouvez le signaler notamment
à la plateforme Pharos.
C'est un site du gouvernement
cybermalveillance.gouv.fr.
Vous pouvez copier le lien surtout sans
le cliquer, mais le copier et leur signaler.
Ils s'occuperont de demander
la mise hors ligne du site.
Et puis tout ce que l'on décrit concernant les mails que l'on peut recevoir,
c'est aussi valable pour les SMS.
Absolument.
Les pirates envoient aussi des SMS
avec le même ton un petit peu d'urgence,
des liens à cliquer.
C'est la même chose.
On ne clique pas et on se rend sur le site par sa voie habituelle.
Donc, si je résume : on vérifie le ton
qui est utilisé dans le message,
l'orthographe et l'adresse de l'expéditeur.
C'est tout à fait ça.
Merci beaucoup Axelle. Avec plaisir ! À bientôt ! À bientôt !
Pour protéger nos appareils des intrusions,
nos mots de passe doivent
être les plus résistants possible.
Zéro zéro zéro zéro
un deux trois quatre, non.
Azerty
Sa date de naissance !
C'est quoi déjà ?
Bien tenté !
Il y a là effectivement les mots de passe les plus utilisés en France.
Nous faisons tous cette erreur.
Laisser les mots de passe
définis par défaut sur nos appareils
ou choisir des combinaisons trop simples,
faciles à retenir.
On estime qu'il faut moins d'une seconde pour qu'un
cybercriminel craque ce type de mot de passe.
Prenons un exemple très concret.
Un mot de passe qui utilise votre prénom
ou celui d'un
membre de votre famille associé
à des chiffres qui ont un sens pour vous.
Au hasard, votre département de résidence,
le numéro de votre rue
ou pire, votre date de naissance.
17 janvier ! Mais oui !
Ces détails de votre vie privée
sont beaucoup trop faciles à dénicher.
En quelques clics sur un moteur de recherche ou sur les réseaux sociaux.
Même chose pour votre équipe de foot
préférée ou votre animal fétiche.
Alors, à quoi ça ressemble
un mot de passe vraiment sécurisé ?
À ça !
Oh la la !  C'est en quelle langue ça ?
Plus un mot de passe est long,
plus il est sécurisé.
On parle alors de phrases de passe
écrites en phonétique,
avec des caractères spéciaux et des jeux de mots.
C'est encore mieux.
Mais le top de la sécurisation
reste le mot de passe aléatoire.
Plusieurs sites permettent d'en générer
et les smartphones en proposent de plus en plus.
Une fois que l'on a trouvé un bon mot de passe,
on serait tenté d'utiliser le même partout.
C'est plus facile à retenir.
Mais là encore, c'est
une très mauvaise idée.
Il suffit d'un site moins sécurisé
que les autres
pour que tous vos comptes soient exposés aux pirates.
Donc, dans la mesure du possible :
un compte, un mot de passe.
Comment je vais faire ?!
Je ne vais jamais tout retenir !
Pas de panique ! Il existe des trousseaux sécurisés pour stocker ces mots de passe.
Et puis vous n'êtes pas obligés
de tous les changer d'un seul coup.
La priorité, c'est de sécuriser son compte mail personnel.
C'est la porte qui ouvre toutes les autres.
Si quelqu'un de malintentionné
obtient ce mot de passe.
C'est le jackpot.
Grâce au système de mot de passe oublié, il peut se connecter à
tous les autres comptes.
J'en ai marre !
Et oui mon vieux !
Pour protéger son smartphone des attaques,
là aussi, c'est très simple.
Moi je garde mon téléphone sous clé.
C'est moins pratique pour décrocher. Allô ?
C'est une idée.
Avec un code pour verrouiller son écran ou la carte SIM, c'est déjà pas mal.
Si votre appareil est équipé
de la reconnaissance faciale
ou des empreintes digitales,
c'est encore mieux.
Nous sommes accros aux applis.
En 2021, nous en avons téléchargé
plus de 2 milliards.
Mais attention,
certaines peuvent contenir des virus ou
donner accès à vos données personnelles.
Vérifiez bien qu'elles proviennent
d'un éditeur de logiciels officiel
ou qu'elles ne vous demande pas
des autorisations d'accès farfelues.
Méfiance, par exemple,
si un simple jeu de mots croisés
vous demande d'accéder à vos contacts
ou à vos SMS.
En plus,
la plupart des applis continuent de
fonctionner si on leur refuse ces accès.
Autre point faible,
les ports de recharge de nos appareils.
Quand nos batteries
sont à sec en cours de journée,
on est souvent tenté de se brancher
sur l'une
des nombreuses bornes de recharge
installées dans les lieux publics.
Le risque, c'est que des pirates
infectent ces bornes et s'en servent
pour espionner les contenus
de nos téléphones ou pour y installer
un logiciel malveillant.
Le plus sûr, c'est donc d'avoir ses
propres batteries de secours.
Dernier conseil : faites bien les mises à jour.
Elles contiennent le plus souvent
des améliorations de sécurité.
Allez, un petit dernier pour la route !
Ne jouez pas au codeur
en essayant de débloquer le logiciel
d'exploitation de votre smartphone.
On casse souvent au passage
des barrières de sécurité bien utiles.
Voilà, avec tout cela, vous avez les clés
pour rester connectés en toute sécurité.
À très bientôt,
sur les réseaux Epicurieux.
La cybersécurité nous concerne tous.
Dommage...
Si vous... Dommage !
Avec, c'est ça.
Mais je ne vais jamais tout retenir !
C'est un cauchemar ! Je reprends.